let's talk about how to boost your
creativity with non-time
secret used by steve jobs einstein and
other
neuroscientists as business insider at a
time when many of us are working
remotely due to the pandemic it can be
difficult to access
access your creative spark especially if
you've settled
into a routine non-time a secret
followed by great minds
from apple steve jobs so scientist
albert einstein is the art of doing
nothing but thinking journalist writer
and speaker
stephen cutler who authored the art of
impossible earlier this year coined the
concept of non-time as period
of taking break from the sensory
bombardment of the world
writer for writing for ted talks kotler
said non-time is time for daydreaming
and psychological distancing and
allowing our subconscious to find remote
associations between ideas he also cited
the importance of stepping away from
deadlines calling them kryptonite for
creativity and also underlining the
importance of solitude thoughts
i mean i love this story i love this
story i mean every morning you would
i do i mean look if it's good enough for
einstein and steve jobs it's good enough
for
adam's can you tell us your morning
routine so yeah you have a union i i've
done a morning routine for the last five
years
and um i'm up at you know give or take
depending on what the podcast is
somewhere around seven o'clock right
that's my time if when the podcast
starts earlier a little bit closer to
six
the first hour of my day i chug water
i just i think i chill
and i'll do yoga stretching for a half
hour i just stay flexible
i think i i um do an affirmation i say
positive thoughts
and it it's when you start your day and
you get to the office and next thing you
know you're doing a podcast and then you
got to return emails
you got conference calls and you got to
go get lunch and then you gotta
it's so hard to find that time to do
that and something that you always talk
about is we got to find time to have
just
creative meetings we got to have find
time just to have brainstorming sessions
and because in the monotony of the day
it's so hard to get that so
for me for people out there obviously if
you get a rush out of the office i had
the luxury of working from home remotely
for
the past seven years and then now i'm
coming in an office every day ironically
but i take the first hour of my day just
to get my mind right
and um meditation yoga mindfulness
stretching whatever it is for you uh i
highly recommend it i
i actually had um dinner and drinks with
i won't say his name but probably the
biggest guy in the nightlife world in
miami
and you're talking about a guy for years
would be in fist fights
just just crazy he's a brooklyn guy
just and i go so tell me about what
you're up to these days he goes every
morning
i meditate for an hour and he goes i
can't tell you
how much better my life is so
mindfulness
and just wellness is is a thing these
days it's a real thing and i encourage
everyone to check it out i want to do
more of it
i don't know if you if this is something
you have uh somebody said right there
adam's comparing himself to einstein
this is is exciting
well he was a uh european jew just like
my people so there is some
comparison there tom you're in la you
got all this you know green stuff going
on
who the hell is einstein in jobs to give
us any advice what have they done
uh you know what for geniuses like that
i mean
einstein could take a three-hour nap and
invent a new flying frisbee uh
something you know these guys are flying
frisbee wow that's intense um
this doesn't work for me i i don't need
down time i don't like down time
i'm uh i run from downtime for me it
just doesn't work i like chaos
and i i even at night i like chaos what
do you mean what do you mean i can't
sleep for more than three or four hours
at a time
i gotta get up walk around do something
look at some stories do some things but
maybe that's why you need
so maybe you know down time maybe i do i
think it just depends for each uh
individual but i think a lot of people
might take this advice and just go with
the doing nothing part
right and forget about the butt thinking
so i
it's it's interesting i can definitely
see some therapeutic
advantages for some people and it's
probably a really good thing
i just don't think i could you know take
it too have you ever done anything like
this
oh i i like listen actually for me i
think
uh i call it alone time not non-time i
like to sit there grab a paper and pen
and think
and i'll play a song it's it's by this
guy that plays a piano i obviously can't
play it or else the video would be
uh uh uh private i play video i play uh
uh
uh uh the song piano and i listen to it
and i think and i write and i look at
data and i look at articles and i'll
just sit there thinking what if we did
this and what if we did that and what if
we did that
i'm fully for it on doing that and
obviously prayer
god knows how effective it is to pray
and to meditate you know
yoga is a very good thing i used to do
yoga regularly religiously
and uh bikram yoka it was phenomenal for
me
so i can totally see a uh correlation
between this and that and at the same
time i relate to time as well if you go
on vacation with me i'm a three-day guy
i can't go some of these guys go for two
weeks three weeks
i'm terrible for two or three weeks you
go with vacation you go with me for
three days you'll have the time of your
life the moment we get into seven days
you're gonna say pat can we just go back
to work and do something
but for three days you'll have a lot of
fun with me what is it in your dna that
you can't check out i have more than
three i have to build i am
i'm a creator i'm a builder i got to
build things i got to go
make progress towards something so if
we're there past three days now we have
to compete who swims the fastest now we
have to go out there and see
if we can swim across to the island
across to us can we make it in the next
hour and let's try this and let's
plus you'd be antsy and you'd be not as
much fun to be around because your mind
would be elsewhere my mind would be
healthy that's why i'm three days three
days time of your life fourth day
as we all know your mind might be
telling you no
but your body your body
might be telling you yes you know that
song r kelly
there you go tom he got it so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye